five another step in the long road to
bring pot lounges to the city of Las
Vegas today the city council will vote
on regulations to allow them the lounges
were approved in Clark County set to
open by the end of the year so far
though the city has yet to vote on
specific regulations Lauren Grady
joining us live this morning to break
down the agenda item and what they might
be looking at Lauren good morning
good morning you guys that's right the
Las Vegas city council is considering
adopting a bill that paves the way for
those pot lounges in southern Nevada
Henderson North Las Vegas Boulder City
and Mesquite opted out of the process
before now these businesses would sell
or provide single use ready to consume
cannabis products for people over 21
years to use on the premises in a
designated area the regulations include
plans to prevent miners from entering
lounges safety measures and the rule
that there cannot be smoking outside or
in public view there would be a one-time
origination charge it's ten thousand for
a lounge that's attached to a pot store
and 2500 for an independent one live in
The Newsroom Lauren negretti 8 News Now